guten morgen ich bin nur noch müde
ich wünsche mir irgendwas hart weil ich
ständig müde bin ich glaube ich bin
einfach nur kaputt von
länder aus das video heute packen wir
den adventskalender von mymuesli aus
woher kam plötzlich diese energie
fragt ihr euch auch völlig zurecht
vanessa müsli das nicht verlangen weil
ich ja glaube ich auch aber ich fand den
so schön und irgendwie so gut gemacht
was ich dachte kommt dann habe ich jetzt
halt müsli zu hause natürlich noch
meinen zuschauern was und dann ist gut
schaut mal was das für eine riesen box
ist es ist wirklich so schwer weil ich
gute das müsli das wiegt wird und leute
und das design ist einfach herrlich hat
soll man dazu sagen das weckt winter
weihnachtliche gefühle in einem
weihnachts
und das ist tipptopp toll der grenz 360
grad also türchen auf jeder seite und
ich habe noch nie mein müsli gegessen
ich hab's geschafft und am ganzen leben
noch nie mein michel zu essen das ist
auch eine errungenschaft so was hat er
denn gekostet mein müsli
129 euro was war mit mir los ist gut das
ist der deluxe adventskalender also
besser geht nicht und es soll nicht nur
müsli drin sein deswegen habe ich den
mann auch bestellt weil ich dachte dass
interessierte stück schüssel und
minister wie auch im stahl also lasst
uns frühstücken wenn ihr gerne essens
geräusche hören könnt dann ist das video
vielleicht nicht für euch oder es gibt
dann einmal wenn ich was diese ging es
schon wieder so groß dass überhaupt
nicht
einfach super als wenn ich vor dem
schotten micro dass das ding riesig
wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an ich bin
sehr gespannt ich freue mich und bevor
ich irgendwann türlich ein sehr finde
ich das konzept ganz gut weil man macht
ja morgens natürlichen auf und was
braucht man morgens müsli tja jetzt
jetzt seien über führende marken 1
safety ocean wo siehst du wir geben
unser bestes für eine schnelle
umstellung mymuesli versucht jetzt auch
nachhaltiger zu werden pappbecher und
das hier soll dann anscheinend irgendwie
kompostiert des plastik sein junges
leben dinkel quinoa crunchy cacau könnte
ihm sauer kirchen wow das klingt richtig
gut mai mosley to go ist dass luca gut
die sauerkirschen haben wir schon auf
16,9 gramm pro 100 gramm hier sind 85
gramm drin also ist in fast 16 gramm
zucker und ich kann ja nicht 100 warum
auch machen deswegen will ich das noch
nicht probieren ich warte mit kleinen
türchen nummer zwei ist ganz ganz klein
die haben jetzt auch schokoriegel
chocolate barry gambio ohne panne auch
schon wieder 18 gramm so kann darf es
nicht verwechselt was gesundes das ist
so ein schneller snack würde ich eher
sagen
ich meinen traumjob mit daten
heidelbeeren
vergessen ist gesagt der ist doch nicht
so schlecht sind 60% datteln und daher
kommt wahrscheinlich auch der
zuckeranteil haben sie noch einen kubus
blüten zucker drin ich will gar nicht
sagen dass er nicht gesund ist weil das
ist bestimmt quatsch dieses zucker thema
das ich habe jetzt auch sein ich weiß
wir sollten den preis nachrechnen vom
preis sagt mein müsli das etwa 129 90
kostet aber man sich 30 euro spart also
müsste der eigentlich 159 90 kosten
rechnen wir mal 99
91 für so ein riegel ist das okay zwei
euro kosten solche dinge an technik und
zwei
golden god 1990 also
1990 durch ein euro 65 kirchen mit drei
business cookie
canola-future
max richtung wie du rates kekse weiße
schoko sterne und apfelstücke ist das
meine ich
das nicht
könnt ihr die schoko sterne erklären
und spekulatius und da ist zwar ein
bisschen schokolade drin arbeit probiere
es trotzdem
ein kleiner lipuma
decke ach die sind gar nicht aus pappe
das macht ja auch keinen sinn man soll
da ja milch rein füllen die sind schon
aus plastik in drin
und rein dafür zu groß ist wirklich
praktisch
also mir gefällt diese weihnachtliche
mischung hier sehr es hat nicht so süß
wie man immer denkt
ist eine tolle mischung der
weihnachtlichen nummer vier
haben gewürz tree of organic green
garten bloß und kräutertee mit demenz
liebe fans temperaments apfelstücke
hagebutte verloren
die trophy ist eine marke der mymuesli
gmbh
jetzt umgehen auf 60 gramm kosten 10 90
das und 20 gramm also durch
63 5 noch ein müsli
harrys ortet carroll mit granulat das
weihnachtssingen aufgemacht misst
sinnvoll die großen stücke darin seht
carroll cracks himbeere blaubeere
schlecht lecker schmeckt ja es ist schon
sehr sehr gut schreib mal wieder ein eur
65 auf so nikolaus ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass sie ein nikolaus kainz
passion gemacht haben hier oben ist die
6 ihr seht es zuerst
das ist doch mal ein special das ist das
schöne design ich habe aber keine therme
fläche an meine freude kommt immer mit
einer werbefläche zu mir immer von
eifersüchtig weil sie dann aus ihrer
therme flasche trinkt
cola hat man ein baby
und dann macht man hier sich sein tier
ein hammer
und dann hast du noch einen praktischen
griff und dann läufst du durch den wald
spazieren und dann bereits überarbeitet
schöner tag heute ist leute ich bin fan
dann kann ich die da rein machen wir
einen geraden wald spazieren gehen
verkaufen sie die flasche sogar auf der
website schrieb die 26 euro kostet die
therme flasche im shop aber die mt sieht
die praktische das im
bettchen nummer 7
was haben wir
da braucht man jetzt eine mikrowelle
keine mikrowelle dass man gebe ich das
weg aber college heute ist aber auch das
einfachste frische was man sich zu hause
selber kann haferflocken in den dort
vielleicht noch ein bisschen apfel zimt
irgendwie soweit und rühren bis hierhin
aufkochen wirklich nur ganz kurz und
dann ist es fertig da finde ich mich
sollte man halt fertig kaufen
meine eltern sind so fried die essen
seit jahren gleich müsli was sie sich
selbst zusammenstellen paar flocken
nüsse rosinen und das kippen sich dann
immer in ihrem behälter schön einmal
dann haben sie gemacht
hat ist das denn diese mymuesli gmbh
alles raus gebracht ich dachte du dich
machen immer einfach nur müsli handel
ist doch wir glauben an die pflanzlichen
zukunft wie wir 250 milliliter 1 euro 80
also das ist keine mehr woraus besteht
sie ohne zucker ohne zusatz von zucker
auch hier wieder bio also die legen sehr
viel wert auf bio besteht aus hardware
gekühlt trinken
ja vielleicht sollte man das nicht
gekühlt trinken ich glaube der geschmack
passt gerade nichts zu dem müsli was ich
eben wieder gegessen haben also sind
kein cacau der mich so umschaue sage ok
man kann einpacken aber das was
besonderes also der bananen geschmack
schmeckt besonders und man soll es
vielleicht wirklich gekühlt trinken
kommen wir zu meiner lieblingszahl
türchen nummer 9 und da wird jetzt ein
absolutes lieblings mix wie drin sein
business shop cacau kino artikulierten
gebrannten haselnüssen und
zartbitterschokolade das ist aber auch
alles so lecker finde ich cool dass sie
extra weihnachts sorten haben
jeden morgen jetzt wieder ein suchteam
ein weihnachtsstern herz geht hier
richtig auf also ich finde diesen
kalender so man muss ja auch mal die
illustratoren dahin haben
mit helsinn hat am main oder mandel
kokos canola gerösteten haselnüssen
dunklen schokolade bleibt das klingt
jetzt eben ja aber da
kann man sie ja gar nicht vorstellen
dass das ein gesundes frühstück ist ich
weiß es ehrlich gesagt ich bin kein
frühstücks expertin
irgendwie schon laktosefrei drauf stehen
mein gott das passt also ich finde was
verpackung und so was angehen ein
lebensgefühl verkaufen das kann man nie
wie schon zieht einfach hübsch
ausgebrannte haselnuss cranberry in
dunkler schokolade rio vegan laktosefrei
willst du mich verarschen
so sehen die aus
[Musik]
die haselnüsse sind dafür umso besser
haben sehr leckeres und erkenne ich aber
vom luchs ein bisschen um sieben
millionen 120 gramm ist hier mal wieder
ein puls 4 euro 90 nummer 12
praktischer schopf
ja praktischer schraubverschluss
integrierter topping behälter und löffel
behälter optisch mal wieder eine 10 von
10 ich weiß ich wie das mein müsli macht
aber es sieht alles gut da ist sogar
vorne sein herz war was ist denn jetzt
der löffel
willst du mich verarschen wie toll
also natürlich ein kleiner der betrieb
hat man seine toppings rein da sein
müsli und dann bei der arbeit gibt man
sich das dann so
ein land mit ich meine das einzige
problem ist ich gehe nirgendwo hin aber
zufällig mein bahnen so das ist dann
wieder praktisch wenn ich mir das
vorstelle leute wenn ich das zu
schulzeiten mit in die schule genommen
hätte excuse me ich mache hier gratis
also wenn du da noch so eine kleine
milch dabei hast sogar scheiße kriegt
man mit overnight express theater macht
man seine overnight ortsteilen 13 euro
90 du kannst auch ein preis das war
jetzt nummer 12 wir sind mit der hälfte
durch und wir machen weiter mit zwischen
13 und das ist mal wieder ein
riegel larry
dark chocolate müsliriegel den werde ich
jetzt nicht aufmachen ich habe hier noch
mal skurril aber wie ganze jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht oder doch begann
ich denke dass wie immer wieder
kommen die sorten die kling aber auch
barry kam es klingt wie nachtisch wie
das süße leben juni mit weich karamell
und himbeeren ja die vedes karamell ja
sagen ist geil will ich jetzt nicht als
frühstück nummer eins sehen aber lecker
ist es bestimmt nummer 15
kriegen wir wieder ein kunstprodukt tree
of the century chemische mit mango oder
leider kann ich keinen grünen tee
trinken kann einfach und also auch
gerade bei tieren sondern das ist toll
dass den bbi und siegel haben
wir haben 129 euro dafür bezahlt es
müssen ein paar mehr sachen drin sein
als müslis ich freue mich trotzdem
drüber fruchtbar mischung mit himbeeren
erdbeeren und hafer vollkornmehl
haferflocken schroth macht man das denn
100 milliliter wasser flüssigkeit und 50
gramm pulver nur mit flüssigkeit
vermischen
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das in
die verlosung mit rein packe deswegen
mache ich jetzt nicht auf aber das
system finde ich mega geil dann hörst du
das nur ahnen hast du deine musik aber
ich diese musik auch mal kalt gerne esse
also man muss das irgendwie noch kalt
hinbekommt kalten wasser oder milch
sondern siebold die so richtig schön
kalt ist ich möchte hat auch immer als
obmann eisbecher ist aber kommt optisch
ist das ja mal wieder eine 10 von 10 was
soll denn das wird eure 90 17
jetzt geht es aber los also ich mag die
verteilung es ist sehr ausgeglichen hier
haben wir ein richtiges müsli also eine
volle packung kein to go becher sind
schafe sind crunchy schoko zimt
schneemänner weiße dinkel welchen viel
liebe das sind tolle zutaten das sieht
einfach gut aus dass in der küche steht
soll man da sagen jetzt richtig geil an
milch frei das finde ich gut wie kann
dann durch lee so hinkriegen wie kann
man müsli so verkaufen als ob so ein
lifestyle-produkt wer wirklich feier ist
einfach aber es ist nur müsli
macadamia sind
lugano mit apfelstücken macadamia und
deutet körner christie's natürlich was
auch sonst hatte ich muss mir mein neues
leben aber da ist es ganz schön
aus meinem müsli kann jetzt schon
porridge machen und habt ein bisschen zu
lang stehen lassen das haben sie
wahrscheinlich so oft gedreht dass
irgendwann aus den crunchy nut mann
chinas geworden ist kirche nummer 19
nach
butter balls haben sie das sind schon
wieder so stylisch aus
es spricht mich zu an haselnuss wandeln
und china und dann sind das so gollia
ich verstehe den mandelkern harmlos
heraus wir probieren die mandeln in zehn
bisschen billig aus als auf einer seite
sind sie dann schon ähnlich aus hier
gehen sie
[Musik]
die sind gut wenn man so richtig hunger
hatten ganz schnell ganz viele
energiepreise ist auf natel drücken
es ist auch da windows basis gefüllt mit
mandeln muss deshalb wirklich machen
will muss in der mitte lecker schmecker
98 mymuesli ich glaube an dieser stelle
ist es für uns alle klar nächstes jahr
machen die kooperation zusammen zwar auf
ihren anruf
mit orange und erdbeeren den behalte ich
für mich
114 90 wie viel ist hier drin 30 eur 27
okay ganz großer minuspunkt wollte
gerade die eine auf die andere stapeln
aber sie fühlen sich nicht zusammen das
heißt wenn ihr euch mehrere von den
holen vielleicht kannst du die special
mini dinge 21 jahren
aber ich bin jetzt echt ein bisschen ein
riegel blueberry vanilla eine tolle
mischung hat man blaubeeren vanille
kuchen gemacht ein euro 90 das wissen
wir doch mittlerweile so was sagt
eigentlich zu meinem schlafanzug ich hab
meinen schlafanzug extra von meinem
harry potter haus gekauft also reden
klingt ein bisschen griffen dort drin
weil so ein teil in mir ist auch größen
dort aber eigentlich bin ich raven klopp
das problem ist nämlich beim schlafen
ich kann nicht mit nackten arme schlafen
wenn diese seite von meinen armen kalt
wird täglich halsschmerzen sobald ich
dann wieder was drauflegen es könnte
auch unseren stoff sind der hier liegt
dann ist gut dass sie trage ich solche
petersberg schlafen
22 lange her lange ist es ja cherry
stracciatella müslis leute das ist müsli
puffer crunchy sauerkirschen und
zartbitterschokolade plättchen cherry
stracciatella 122 holz ist für
[Musik]
die sorten die klingen würde nicht nach
müssen sondern nach einfach das bestimmt
die maschen von meinen müssen und wir
sind angekommen bei der 24 habe ich noch
mal diesen teil adventskalender an so
und jetzt machen wir die 24 auf es ist
heiligabend ich habe diesen pyjama an
den plan ich auch natürlich an
weihnachten an zu haben ist doch klar
hat diesen pyjama an ich bin meine haare
gebunden ist renne ich die treppe runter
an meinem weihnachtsbaum vorbei zum beim
adventskalender und ich sagte was ist
denn drin
und mymuesli sagt
ich weiß es nicht
do&co becher aus pilawas ist petar klima
positiv aus pflanzen produziert immer
dabei aus
biokunststoff müsli und mehr mitnehmen
frische links ok ich
weine gleich aber es liegt an taylor
swift und diesen blöden song ich fühle
mich seit tagen ist ob ich liebe es
kommen hätte aktuell alter das ist ja
nicht nur ein müsli schiffe das kann man
ja auch wenn zb für salat nehmen oder so
du sagst du einfach mal habe ich hier
dann mein meint ist und dann ist hier
meine feuchten zutaten und dann möchte
ich das zusammen und habe salat oder
spülmaschinenfest gefrier geeignet
lebensmittelecht mikrowellen fällt und
man 10 euro gutschein
rechts sind ja da ist wunderschön und
ich bin einfach emotional gerade also
[Musik]
wunderbares 24 türchen ich fühle mich
sehr abgeholt aber auch 129 4 dieses
ging ausgegeben habe alleine von den
special
bin ich denn jetzt rechnen wir mal
zusammen ich bin auf
153 euro 97 gekommen 129 90 mg zahl ja
wie nicht gesagt 30 euro also ungefähr
30 euro bekommt man on top ich denke mal
wenn man bei müsli fan ist dann ist es
eine coole möglichkeit man darf aber
nicht so viel fern sein dass man diese
sachen noch nicht hatten aber ich habe
wirklich keine thermoskanne und ich habe
wirklich keine to go becher für müsli
und so einen kram singen freue ich mich
extrem wenn man sowas dann vielleicht
schon zu hause hat denn es ist too much
aber finde die auswahl sehr
abwechslungsreich auch mit dem tee und
die verschiedenen müsli sorten das finde
ich halt auch
und dann hatten wir sogar noch
müsliriegel und diese nüsse und porridge
und des musik und nackt boys ja also man
zahlt 129 euro was absolut nicht wenig
geld ist also das ist wirklich so ein
luxus adventskalender also ich würde
schon sagen das ist so absolut obere
kategorie aber der inhalt ist halt auch
cool also ist alles bio ich kann mich
jetzt mit der marke mini klinik so sehr
aus aber mein erster eindruck ist cool
ich mag das konzept ich finde frühstück
als adventskalender ist einfach
praktisch weil man morgens in der länder
auf macht und dann kann man ihn morgens
gleich mal was essen und ja hab mir
gerne was ihr dazu sagt wie ihr den so
findet und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten video wieder und jetzt bin ich
wirklich in weihnachtsstimmung der
kalender hat mich in weihnachtsstimmung
versetzt liegt aber auch einfach an
diesem tollen illustration wenn die
wirklich sehr sehr schön dann sehen wir
uns beim nächsten mal hier
slide to lose you merry christmas world
tschüss das dann frohe weihnachten bis
bald